um so question for you guys i don't know
who wants to take this but there's
always the bro that's like just eat
healthy train hard sleep well now i take
this off
so there so one thing i didn't mention
is i got my bachelor environmental
science and before i wanted to work in
supplements
um we did this study on soil quality
from 1970 versus 2002
and what we found in the soil in 1970 is
that
there were what stuck out to me zinc
magnesium and selenium were so much more
barren in soil
today or i guess that's 20 years ago or
2002 yeah almost 20 years ago compared
to soil in the 1970s so if your soil
doesn't have those minerals there's a
high chance your vegetables don't have
those minerals and i wish i remember the
date but we were actually at a
conference with um
he's an old ufc fighter his name's guy
metzger i don't know if you remember him
back in the day
he actually his second career is a phd
in naturopathic and nutritional medicine
and we were we were at a place with a
bunch of strength coaches and he was
like in his opinion everyone needs to
supplement because they haven't changed
the supplement facts on
food in something like 50 years so when
you think you're eating an apple and
you're seeing the supplement facts that
apple that's from 1950s apple not from a
current day apple
and most people can't get adequate
nutrient levels just by eating
a because the food doesn't have it and b
because their digestion isn't the same
as it used to be either um
um let me go back i don't know if that
was too long-winded no hey listen you
know geek right out i mean we got 90
minutes for this show so i mean i'm
going to never talk as long as you guys
want did you want to add to that to uh
melissa or
i mean yeah i wish it could be that
simple but we just don't live in the
same world that our grandparents lived
in
there's certain foundational supplements
like vitamin d magnesium you can get
this also just by taking a good quality
multivitamin like alpha burn
you're not getting it through your food
and that hurts me as a nutritionist to
say that however eating healthy and
doing the work is love the shirt is the
first step
but supplements are
very important especially if you have
goals and
this is it really just comes down to
this do you want to be average and hit
your rdas or do you want to perform
optimally i have no intention of being
average therefore i'm supplementing to
make sure that i can perform optimally
so if you're cool just being at that
basic level then continue to eat the
food that you're eating and make good
choices but if you want to perform at
any higher level than that or you train
or you're a parent or an entrepreneur
you're going to want to supplement i
love everybody
on that one melissa
you